me
so
um
[Music]
foreign
bye
so
[Music]
is
is all
[Music]
god is light in whom there is no
darkness at all
and this is the judgment
that the light has come into the world
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
be
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
so
dear people of god
in this holy week let us hear once more
of our lord's passion and death
with heart and mind
let us go to gethsemane
and to the halls of judgment and yes
even to the hill
of calvary
let us hear in holy scripture the story
of god's loving purpose in christ's
suffering
and his ultimate sacrifice for all
humankind
but first
let us pray for the needs of the whole
world for peace and justice on earth
for the unity and mission of the church
for which he died
let us remember in christ's name the
poor
and the helpless
the cold
and the hungry
and the oppressed
all who are sick and who mourn the
lonely
and unloved
the aged and the little
children as well as those who do not
know
and love the lord jesus christ
we remember all those who rejoice with
us but upon another shore
and in greater light that multitude
which no one can number whose hope was
in the crucified and risen lord
let us pray that we may be taught
humility as we remember christ's
humiliation that we may be taught
obedience
as we remember christ's obedience
unto death
and that we might be taught to love one
another
as we remember christ's love for all
people
finally
let us pray for all those things
for which our lord would have us ask
as we pray the prayer of his heart
our father
who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come
thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not to temptation
but deliver us from evil
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory forever
oh my people
my church
what have i done to you
or in what
have i offended you that you should
testify against me
i led you forth from the land of egypt
and delivered you by the waters of
baptism
but you have prepared a cross
for your savior
i led you through the desert for forty
years and fed you with manna
i brought you through tribulation and
pestilence
and gave you my body the bread of heaven
but you have prepared a cross for your
savior
i went before you in a pillar of cloud
and you have led me to the judgment hall
of pilate
i scourged your enemies and brought you
to a land of freedom but you have
scourged mocked and beaten me
i gave you the water of salvation from
the rock
but you have given me gall
and left me to thirst
and you have prepared a cross for your
savior
[Music]
i gave you a royal scepter and bestowed
the keys to the kingdom
but you have given me a crown of thorns
i raised you on high with great power
but you have prepared a cross
for your savior
lord have mercy
my peace i gave
which the world cannot give and washed
your feet as a sign of my love
but you draw the sword
to strike in my name
and seek high places
in my kingdom
i offered you my body and blood but you
scatter and deny and abandon me
and you have prepared a cross
for your savior
i sent the spirit of truth to guide you
and you close your hearts to the
counselor
i pray that all may be one in the father
and me but you continue to quarrel and
divide
i call you to go
and bring forth fruit but you cast lots
for my clothing
and you have prepared a cross
for your savior
i came to you as the least of your
brothers and sisters i was hungry and
you gave me no food i was thirsty and
you gave me no drink i was a stranger
and you did not welcome me naked and you
did not clothe me sick and in prison and
you did not visit me and you have
prepared a cross for your savior
were you
there when they
crucified my lord
were you
there
when they
crucified my
[Music]
sometimes
it
causes me
to tremble
tremble
[Music]
were you there
when they
my lord
[Music]
in the upper room
on the first day of unleavened bread the
disciples came to jesus saying
what do you want us to make preparations
for you
to eat the passover
he said
go into the city
to a certain man
and say to him
the teacher says
my time is near
i will keep the passover at your house
with my disciples
so the disciples did as jesus had
directed them and they prepared the
passover meal
when it was evening
he took his place with the twelve
and while they were eating he said
truly
truly i tell you
one of you
will betray me
and they became greatly distressed
and began to say to him one after the
other
surely not i lord
he answered
the one who has dipped his hand in the
bowl with me
will betray me
the son of man goes
as it is written of him
but woe to that one by whom the son of
man is betrayed
it would have been better for that one
not to have been born
judas
who betrayed him said
surely not i rabbi
he replied
you have said so
while they were eating jesus took a loaf
of bread
and after blessing he broke it
gave it to the disciples and said take
eat
this is my body
then he took a cup
and after giving thanks he gave it to
them saying
drink from it all of you
for this is my blood of the covenant
which is poured out for many for the
forgiveness of sins
i tell you
i will never again drink of this fruit
of the vine
until that day
when i drink it new with you
in my father's kingdom
[Music]
sacred
is
[Music]
oh
which once was brightest
[Music]
jesus
in gethsemane
then jesus went with them to a place
called gethsemane
and he said to his disciples sit here
while i go over there and pray
he took with him peter and the two sons
of zebedee
and began to be grieved and agitated
then he said to them i am deeply grieved
even unto death
remain here
and stay awake with me
and going a little farther he threw
himself on the ground and prayed
my father if it is possible
let this cup pass from me
yet not what i
want but what you want
then he came to the disciples and he
found them sleeping and he said to peter
so could you not stay awake with me for
one hour
stay awake and pray that you may not
come into the time of trial
the spirit is indeed willing but the
flesh is weak
again he went away for the second time
and prayed
my father
if this cannot pass unless i drink it
your will be done
again he came and found them sleeping
for their eyes were heavy
so leaving them again he went away and
prayed for the third time
saying the same words then he came to
the disciples and said to them
are you still sleeping and taking your
rest
see the hour it is is at hand and the
son of man is betrayed into the hand of
sinners
get up
let us be going
see my betrayer is at hand
[Music]
what wondrous love is this o my soul o
my soul what wondrous
[Music]
for my soul for my soul
for my soul
judas portrays jesus
while he was still speaking judas one of
the twelve arrived
with him was a large crowd
with swords and clubs
from the chief priests and the elders of
the people
now the betrayer had given them a sign
saying the one i will kiss is the man
arrest him
at once he came up to jesus and said
greetings rabbi
and kissed him
jesus said to him
friend
do what you are here to do
then they came and laid hands on jesus
and arrested him
suddenly one of those with jesus put his
hand on his sword drew it and struck the
slave of the high priest cutting off his
ear
then jesus said
to him put your sword back into its
place
for all who take the sword will perish
by the sword
do you not think that i can appeal to my
father and he will at once send me more
than twelve legions of angels
but how then would the scriptures be
fulfilled which say it must happen in
this way
at that hour
jesus said to the crowds
have you come out with swords and clubs
to arrest me as though i were abandoned
day after day i sat in the temple
teaching and you did not arrest me
but all this has taken place
so that the scriptures of the prophets
may be fulfilled
then all the disciples
deserted him
and fled
the high priest questions jesus
those who had arrested jesus took him to
caiaphas the high priest
in
in whose house the scribes and the
elders had gathered
but peter was following him at a
distance
as far as the courtyard of the high
priest
and going inside he sat with the guards
in order to see how this would end
now the chief priests and the whole
council were looking for false testimony
against jesus so that they might put him
to death
but they found none
though many false witnesses came forward
at last two came forward and said
this fellow said
i am able to destroy the temple of god
and to build it in three days
the high priest stood up and said
have you no answer
what is it that they testify against you
but jesus was silent
then the high priest said to him
i put you under oath before the living
god
tell us
if you are the messiah
the son of
god jesus said to him
you have said so
but i tell you
from now on you will see the son of man
seated at the right hand of power and
coming on the clouds of heaven
then the high priest tore his clothes
and said he has blasphemed
why do we still need witnesses
you have heard his blasphemy
what is your verdict
they answered
he deserves
death
then they spat in his face and struck
him and some slapped him saying
prophesy to us you messiah who is it
that struck you
[Music]
oh
was all for sinners
[Music]
my mind was
oh
[Music]
look on me
with thy
faith save to me thy grace
jesus is questioned by pilate
when morning came
all the chief priests and the elders of
the people conferred together against
jesus in order to bring about his death
they bound him
led him away and handed him over to
pilot the governor
now jesus stood before the governor and
the governor asked him
are you the king of the jews
jesus said
you say so
but when he was accused by the chief
priests and elders he did not answer
then pilate said to him
do you not hear how many accusations
they make against you
but he gave him no answer
not even to a single
charge
so that the governor was greatly amazed
[Music]
pilate presents
jesus to the crowd
now at the festival the governor was
accustomed to release a prisoner for the
crowd anyone whom they wanted
at that time they had a notorious
prisoner called
jesus barabbas
so after they gathered pilate said to
them who do you want me to release for
you
jesus barabbas or
jesus who is called the messiah
before he realized that it was out of
jealousy that they had handed him over
while he was sitting on the judgment
seat his wife sent word to him
have nothing to do with that innocent
man for today i have suffered a great
deal because of a dream about him
now the chief priests and elders
persuaded the crowds to ask for barabbas
and to to have jesus killed
the governor again said to them
which of the two do you want me to
release
for you
and they said
barabbas
pilate said to them
then what should i do with jesus who was
called the messiah
all of them said
let him be crucified
then he asked
what
what evil has he done
but they shouted all the more
let him be crucified
[Music]
jesus
is mocked
so when pilate saw that he could do
nothing
but rather that a riot was beginning
he took some water
and washed his hands before the crowd
saying
i am innocent of this man's blood
see to it yourselves
then the people as a whole answered his
blood be on us and on our children
so he released barabbas for them
and after flogging jesus he handed him
over to be crucified
then the soldiers of the governor took
jesus into the governor's headquarters
and they gathered the whole cohort
around him
they stripped him
and put a scarlet robe on him
and after twisting some thorns into a
crown
they put it on his head
they put a reed in his right hand and
knelt before him and mocked him saying
hail king of the jews
they spat on him
and took a reed and struck him on the
head
after mocking him
they stripped him of the robe and put
his own clothes on him
then they led him away
to crucify him
[Music]
there's a
place where mercy reigns
and never dies
there's a
place where streams of grace
[Music]
like a flood
comes
[Music]
i
surrender my life
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus
there's a place
[Music]
my
[Applause]
[Music]
here
my hope is
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
i
surrender my
[Music]
washed white i owe all to
jesus
[Music]
the suffering servant
who has believed what we have heard
and to whom has the arm of the lord been
revealed
for he grew up before him like a young
plant
and like a root out of dry ground
he had no form or majesty that we should
look at him
nothing in his appearance that we should
desire
him
he was despised and rejected by others
a man of suffering
and acquainted with infirmity
and as one from whom others hide their
faces he was despised
and we held him of no account
surely he has borne our infirmities and
carried our diseases
yet we accounted him stricken
struck down by god and afflicted
but he was wounded for our
transgressions crushed for our
iniquities upon him
was the punishment that made us whole
and by his bruises we are healed
all we like sheep have gone astray
we've all turned to our own way
and the lord has laid on him the
iniquity
of us all
he was oppressed
and he was afflicted
yet he did not open his mouth
like a lamb that has led to the
slaughter and like a sheep that before
its shearers is silent
so he did not open his mouth
by a perversion of justice he was taken
away who could have imagined his future
for he was cut off
from the land of the living
stricken
for the transgression
of my people
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
without and
and should i
thank
me
oh let me
never
outlive my love to
jesus
king of the jews
as they went out
they came upon a man
from cyrene named simon
they compelled this man to carry his
cross
and when they came to a place called
golgotha
which means place of a skull
they offered him wine to drink mixed
with gall
but when he tasted it
he would not drink it
and when they had crucified him
they divided his clothes among
themselves by casting lots
then they sat down there
and kept watch
over him
over his head they put the charge
against him which read
this is jesus
the king
of the jews
[Music]
oh
when i
come to die
oh when i
oh
when i
come
to die
give me jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
all this world
give me jesus
[Music]
dark
midnight
was my cry
dark midnight
dark
midnight was morning cry
give me jesus
[Music]
may have all this world
give me jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
you
may have all this world
with its
troubles and cares
for of this i am
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
jesus
is crucified
then two bandits were crucified with him
one on his right
one on his left
those who had passed by derided him
shaking their heads and saying
you
who would destroy the temple and build
it in three days
save yourself
if you are the son of god
come down from the cross
in the same way
the chief priests also
along with the scribes and elders were
mocking him saying
he saves others
but he cannot save himself
he is the king of israel
let him come down from the cross now
and we will believe in him
he trusts in god
let god deliver him now if he wants to
for he said
i
am god's son
the bandits who were crucified with him
also taunted him
in the same way
[Music]
were you there
it
causes me to tremble
tremble
[Music]
were you
there
when they
nailed into
the trees
a plea
for deliverance
my god
my god why have you forsaken me
why are you so far from helping me
from the words of my groaning
oh my god i cry by day but you do not
answer and by night but find no rest
yet you are holy
enthroned on the praises of israel in
you our ancestors trusted they trusted
and you delivered them to you they cried
and were saved in you they trusted and
were not put to shame
but i am a worm
and not human scorned by others and
despised by the people all who see me
mock at me
they make mouths at me they shake their
heads
commit your cause to the lord let him
deliver let him rescue the one
in whom he delights
yet it was you
who took me from the womb
you kept me safe on my mother's breast
on you i was cast from my birth
and since my mother bore me
you have been my god
do not be far from me
for trouble is near
and there's no one to help
many bowls encircle me strong bowls of
bashan surround me they open wide their
mouths at me like a ravening and roaring
lion
i am poured out like water
and all my bones are out of joint
my heart is like wax
it is melted within my breast
my mouth
is dried up
like a pot shirt
and my tongue sticks to my jaws
you lay me in the dust of death
for dogs are all around me
a company of evil doers encircles me my
hands and feet have shriveled i can
count all my bones
they stare and gloat
over me
and divide my clothes among themselves
and for my clothing they cast lots
but you o lord do not be far away
o my help come quickly to my aid
deliver my soul from the sword my life
from the power of the dog save me from
the mouth of the lion
from the horns of the wild oxen you have
rescued me
i will tell of your name to my brothers
and sisters in the midst of the
congregation i will praise you
all you who fear the lord praise him all
you offspring of jacob glorify him stand
in awe of him all you offspring of
israel
for he did not despise and abhor the
afflicted affliction of the afflicted
he did not
hide his face from me
but heard when i cried to him
from you comes my praise in the great
congregation my vows i will pay before
those who fear him the poor shall eat
and be satisfied
those who seek him shall praise the lord
may your hearts live forever
all the ends of the earth shall remember
and turn to the lord and all the
families of the nations shall worship
before him
for dominion belongs to the lord
and he rules over the nations to him
indeed shall all who sleep in the earth
bow down
before him shall bow all who go down to
the dust and i shall live for him
posterity will serve him
future generations will be told about
the lord and proclaim his deliverance to
a people yet unborn
saying he
has
done it
[Music]
oh
jesus
[Music]
afflicted
who
was the
guilty
[Music]
who brought this
upon thee
[Music]
lost my
trees on
jesus
[Music]
twas our lord jesus
it was in i
think
i
crucified thee
[Music]
for
me
jesus
was the
incarnation
by
mortal
sorrows
[Music]
for
my salvation
[Music]
jesus
since i cannot
pay
thee
i
do
want to
i will
[Applause]
[Music]
and thy love on swirling
not my desert
[Music]
jesus dies on the cross
from noon on
darkness came over the whole land until
three
in the afternoon
and about three o'clock
jesus cried with a loud voice
that is
my god my god
why have you forsaken me
when some of the bystanders heard it
they said this man is calling for elijah
at once one of them ran and got a sponge
filled it with sour wine put it on a
stick and gave it to him to drink
but the other said wait
let us see whether elijah will come to
save him
then jesus cried again with a loud voice
and breathed
his last
um
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
a jesus
yes
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
so
is
[Music]
the soldiers pierce
jesus's side
since it was the day of preparation
the jews did not want the bodies left on
the cross
during the sabbath
especially because that sabbath was a
day of great solemnity
so they asked pilate
to have the leg of the crucified men
broken and the bodies removed
then the soldiers came and broke the
legs of the first and of the other who
had been crucified with him
but when they came to jesus
and saw that he was already dead
they did not break his legs
instead one of the soldiers pierced his
side with a spear and at once blood and
water came out
he who saw this has testified so that
you may also believe his testimony is
true and he knows that he tells the
truth
these things occurred so that scripture
might be fulfilled none of his bones
shall be broken
and again another passage of scripture
says
they will look on the one
whom they have pierced
where are you
[Music]
were you there
when they pierced
[Music]
sometimes
in
[Music]
jesus is laid to rest in the tomb
when it was evening
there came a rich man from
arimathea
named joseph who was also a disciple of
jesus
he went to pilate and asked for the body
of jesus
then pilate ordered it to be given to
him
so joseph took the body
and wrapped it in a clean linen cloth
and laid it in his own new tomb
which he had hewn in the rock
he then rolled a great stone
to the door of the tomb
and went away
[Music]
he's
peace
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
on you stay
[Music]
is
turn
[Music]
go in peace
may jesus christ who for our sake became
obedient
unto death
even death on a cross
keep you
and strengthen you this night
and forevermore
amen
[Music]
when they laid him in
the tomb
were you
there
when they laid him in
the truth
[Music]
sometimes it
causes me
to tremble
[Music]
were you
there
[Music]
in
you